Heat. Heat.
Good evening, Chatty Cathy's.
I am glad to see everyone smiling or
most of you are smiling this evening and
talkative. So, we're going to start
2 minutes late as I was told.
Uh, for the finance committee agenda, we
are going to start with new resolutions
starting with temporary resolution 9025
coming through economic development and
Miss Hoop
this on. Okay. Um, this is um a blanket
now and then um to cover the grants.
Um, so it's to approve all of the then
and now certificates that may arise in
2026 so that we can pay those invoices
that were incurred in 2025.
>> Okay.
>> And if there's any other
>> and that's for CDBG for community.
>> Yeah, it's for all of them. Ship program
healthy homes grant.
>> Okay.
>> I think that's all of them.
>> Does anyone have any questions on that?
Seeing none, thank you very much. We'll
move on to temporary resolution 9125
coming through finance. That is me and
that is auditor's request for an advance
from the county auditor for
real estate taxes. Yeah.
>> Yes. This is an annual piece that um the
county auditor requires uh to be
approved through city council. So, when
they been start sending out the uh uh
real estate tax bills and they start
collections, um I usually like to
request cash advances. That way, the
money gets into our bank account rather
than sitting in the county's bank
account. So, I have to have this passed
in order to request
those advance of funds every year. So,
it's an annual piece that I got to do it
for each um calendar year.
Okay. Any questions on that one?
And now all of a sudden we're not chatty
at all.
>> Okay. Temporary resolution 9225 coming
through administrative services. Mr.
Luxembourg.
>> Well, I'm going to be chatty.
>> Perfect.
>> I'm going to be a little bit chatty
about this because I was so impressed by
it. I spent time with Scott Snider at
the IT department today. Uh this uh
resolution is for the renewal of their
enterprise asset and work management
software which I took about a half hour
looking at with Scott earlier today.
It's an incredible program that's put
together by IT but used by LDOT storm
water department water sanitation code
enforcement tree commission and the IT
department keeps track of all of their
assets. uh a work history of all the
daily projects that all those
departments do, generates all kinds of
reports for all the departments, helps
each department manage tasks, and he
gave me a couple of examples that I
thought would be interesting just for
you all to know about this software. Uh
all the departments use it. Well, a lot
of the departments use it, but uh for
instance, LDOT, how it takes care of
potholes around town. We're all familiar
with all the potholes.
They have a map that locates every
pothole that is brought to to their
attention throughout the city and
indicates when the city was notified
about it, when each pothole is scheduled
to be filled. It keeps track of the
quantities of fill material for all the
potholes used on any given day, the
hours involved, the wages involved of
all the people doing it, the equipment
and the equipment costs. I mean, it's
amazing software. And then it generates
a report that uh they use uh sanitation
if extra trash is left next to a garbage
can. The the garbage man will take a
picture of the trash on his iPad uh make
a note on his iPad as the date and the
location. It automatically goes into
this software and and keeps track of it
and tells them uh how much is there. it
automatically sends a report to the
department that uh uh bills and then the
bill is uh and added added to their bill
that person's bill. It's just an amazing
amazing software and all of LDOT storm
water sanitation code enforcement trees
and the IT department all use it. It's
an amazing amazing system. It's up for
renewal. It's a three-year contract and
um
they are going for a little bit more
this year because the current software
can only be utilized by 130 city
employees and they already have more
than that that are utilizing it. Um and
but they and parks department and water
pollution control wants to get in on it
as well. So, they're gonna have they
need to upgrade the software so that
they can put more people on it. Um, so
anyway, that's that's what we have
before us and we'll go three readings
and Joe will be my second on this.
>> Great. Any questions on that?
[snorts]
>> Okay, moving on. Temporary resolution
9325 coming through finance. Um, I'm
going to These are new appropriations
through the income tax fund. Miss
Hamilton is approaching. You're up here
for this one and the next one. Yeah,
>> I am.
>> Yep.
>> It's all you.
>> This is kind of my annual piece that I
do towards the end of the year. I take a
look at my cash balance, excuse me. And
see what I have left in my expense
budget to pay and what I need to cover
in the next year. And then I try to
allocate as much out in an additional
tax split to police, fire, parks,
everybody who who benefits from that. So
this is what this piece is. It's to
split $5 million, go three readings, no
issues.
Any questions on this piece?
Okay, that one's three readings. Mr.
Sullie is going to be my second. And
then the next one for use temporary
resolution 9425.
Hotel Motel.
>> The next one is Hotel Motel and I
carried over a little more cash into
this year than I anticipated. Um, when
we get our quarterly payments, the
fourth quarter usually hits after the
last pay period in December with the
auditor's office. So, it becomes a
timing issue. And so, I never I kind of
best guess what my appropriation
budget's going to be in this account.
Um, so it was a little bit more than I
thought carrying over and I'm going to
be ending a little bit higher, too. So,
I've cushioned it just a little bit so
that way I can go ahead and pay that
money out now and hopefully carry over a
little less into 2026. So,
>> okay.
[clears throat]
Should I ask if there's any questions
[snorts] on that one?
Self-explanatory. Great. And then three
readings is good on that one as well.
>> Perfect.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Uh last resolution we have introduced
tonight is 9525
coming through finance again and this is
the auditor's annual piece.
>> Um in this piece it's kind of the annual
piece that I I'm going through as as
everybody else is looking at 2026. I'm
centered on 2025 budget true upping so
to speak uh the 2025 expense budgets to
cash on hand by December 31st. So I'm
going through for people set their
budgets this time last year based upon
an estimated revenue. I have to go
through and bring their expense budgets
in line with their actual revenues that
they receive. So this is you'll see this
budget. It's lowering people's current
expense budgets um to bring them in line
with their cash balance that they should
have by the end of December. And I did
add to this one um that Sean Fowler for
sanitation has brought in as as the
wherees he's he had me add in there has
brought in for hauling um a little bit
more than he anticipated and he's going
to need that additional money to pay
invoices to haul the the trash. He hauls
has an invoice every month. So he's
going to run short for that. So, by
130,000.
Any questions?
>> No. Okay.
All right. Ordinances. We have one this
evening that's going to be new. It's
temporary ordinance 6925.
Uh that is coming through
law committee. It's going to be Mr.
Bisjack. Uh thank you, Mr. Chair. Uh
this legislation is very similar to
temporary ordinance 3925. Basically, the
I'm just going to highlight the
differences. I'm not going to go through
every single page um of the these
ordinances, but basically the
significant differences between 6925 and
329 uh 3925 are thus. Um basically any
project where there's five mega there's
a 5 megawatt load or lower um will be
exclusively served by South Central
Power. Uh on top of it, there was also
language added in there that council
will review this agreement every five
years. Outside of that, everything else
is uh the same with 3925 and 6925. Um,
additionally, just to let this body
know, I'm going to be taking 3925 off
the table tonight and withdrawing it. Uh
just so everybody is aware and not
surprised by that motion. So other than
that, I have nothing else to add, Mr.
Chair. Thank you.
um
with the change and not to put him on
the spot, but Mr. Mayor, did you want to
mention anything else on that piece?
>> Well, we've talked about this uh many
times. Uh this is the
most recent uh proposal we had in front
of us here a few weeks ago and uh we
held that special meeting to address
this particular topic. It is certainly
not what South Central Power asked for.
They asked for a higher threshold. It's
not what we originally asked for which
was zero. Um
so after speaking with um several people
in including our economic development
director and uh others uh we felt that
five
megawws was a a compromise we were
willing to accept based on the type of
uh
uh industry it would support. Uh I think
we were given an example magna
out in our industrial park is one
megawws business. So that would be five
magnas uh if you think about it that
way. So we have made a significant
compromise
um but not what the company was asking
for but it is something I believe we can
we can accept.
>> I do have a question. Okay, Miss Tina.
>> So in the future though, if something is
their territory, it's going to stay
their territory that we won't
>> our philosophy has been to honor their
territorial integrity. We just not at
the expense of economic development is
where we we are coming from and that was
the original discussion and we all know
that you know uh that did happen at
South Central Power. someone else did
coming into their territory AAP and is
servicing u the Google development
currently. Um and that that obviously
was one of the reasons South Central
Power was asking for uh more exclusive
uh rights to their territory. uh but but
uh in discussions with not just the city
of Lancaster but other cities, other
mayors in the same and similar
situations where they have two service
providers inside their city. Um
the 5 megawatt threshold is something
that gives some level of protection to
South Central Power and our
philosophical agreement that we do not
ask people uh uh what service provider
they would want. we tell them that
you're in South Central territory or
you're in AP's territory and that is
your service provider. The only time
this ever come up was that one situation
and it was to the benefit of the city to
accept that uh contract that ended up
going to AP instead of South Central and
we saw a significant investment in this
community based on that
>> if they don't want to lose those
opportunities going forward.
>> So that's where we're at. Okay. Any
other questions?
All right. Thanks for that. I was trying
to slow down my meeting.
All right. Uh, department updates where
we are. Anybody with department updates?
Chief Snder.
Good evening, members of council. I'd
like to take this opportunity tonight uh
during finance to highlight a financial
investment that the citizens of Langster
made into their police department. Can
everybody hear me? All right. Okay.
>> Um as you know, a couple of years ago,
we spun up our directive patrol unit. Um
members of council, most of the members
of council here had an opportunity to
have a demonstration of the that
directive patrol unit uh performed for
you here that explained their roles
within the community. Uh, but for those
of you that that do not know what it is
or haven't had that opportunity, I'll
give a really brief explanation. It's a
group or unit of five officers, three K9
officers and two patrol officers that
specifically target quality of life
issues in the city of Lancaster. So, for
instance, your typical patrol officer
that you see on the street. You can give
them neighborhood concerns. You can give
the them issues going on in your
community. Uh, and they will work them
and they'll do their due diligence in
working them. But if they get distracted
or called away to another call for
service or back up somewhere else in the
city, uh they can't concentrate all
their time on that on that quality of
life issue. So the directive patrol unit
compiles all that information to a
database and works that and specifically
targets those issues. And some members
of council have actually utilized that
unit for their constituents when they've
had issues in their area and and they're
very highly effective. Um, the reason
that I another portion of what they do,
unfortunately, the the nationwide drug
epidemic, uh, forces them to conduct a
portion of their, uh, role for narcotics
enforcement, a significant portion. And
the reason I highlight that is it would
be easy for me to stand up here and have
political uh, speak and say, "Hey, if
you invest in the police department,
you'll have a better work product.
You'll have faster response times,
whatever it is." But I think probably
what the citizens are looking for and
what you're looking for is a real world
example on the streets of of the
effectiveness of this unit. And I I have
that uh tonight that I would like to
highlight. Um
you don't mind passing that that way.
>> Thank you.
Holy cow.
So, a short time ago, officer Evanko
with the directive patrol unit is K9
Barry uh had a traffic stop in the city
of Lancaster. And as a result of that
traffic stop, they developed information
that identified and led to one of the
main suppliers of drugs and weapons in
the city of Lancaster. The rest of the
directed patrol unit piled on that
information and over the course of the
next several weeks, worked that
information and conducted additional
traffic stops, obtained additional
statements, conducted other interviews,
and obtained um evidence as a result of
that information and worked that to
further uh concrete the probable cause
on that individual. They relight that
relayed that information to the major
crimes unit who's our investigative arm
for narcotics enforcement locally and
together they worked that information to
develop probable cause on this
individual and we brought in our federal
partners at the ATF to assist with this
um major crimes unit picked up right
where we left off. This this
investigation was worked and just last
week it came to the culmination of what
you see in front of you. The execution
of this search warrant late last week
resulted in the seizure of 18 firearms,
18 handguns, 9 and a half pounds of
methamphetamine,
3.17 pounds of fentanyl, 2.8 pounds of
cocaine along with hundreds of grams of
heroin and Xanax. To put that in
perspective, 2 milligrams of fentanyl
can kill any one of us in this room. So
to take 3.17 pounds off the street means
that's seven over 700,000
lethal doses of fentanyl and those
firearms, methamphetamine, heroin,
cocaine are all off the streets of
Lancaster, Ohio because of the work that
these individuals did. I am infinitely
proud of Officer Evankco and K9 Barry,
Officer Pierce and K9 Omega, Officer
Malone and K9 Mecky, Officer Renie and
Officer Delgado, and the work that all
the men and women at the Langster Police
Department do every single day. I don't
think people get an accurate picture of
the work and the danger these officers
deal with and the the things they take
off the street of this city. And I am
honored to work beside them. And these
guys deserve all the credit. Thank you.
Thank you very much, uh, any other
department updates.
All right, seeing none, move to
President Porter for tonight's meeting
prep.
>> Thank you. We have two council members
who are out this evening, so I'll be
asking that both council member Sie and
Council Member Kites be excused as part
of the meeting agenda. Thank you.
All right, other discussions for
finance. Mr. Bisjack.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chair. Um, everybody
should have at their table, I [snorts]
want to be clear, this is not a piece of
legislation. This is merely just an
idea, a legislative [clears throat]
idea, but I put it in a format that was
tangible and, you know, hopefully easy
for all of us to digest. Um, you know,
obviously I think we're all aware of the
news, all the issues surrounding SNAP
benefits and everything like that and a
lot of uncertainty um that currently is
in our community surrounding those
benefits. Um, I've been reading a lot
more news stories of communities around
Ohio um that are u you know providing
funds for local food pantries um to help
you know folks in this you know terrible
time. So anyway, what this, you know,
idea is looking to accomplish, I came up
with the figure $25,500.
Uh, from conversations I've had, the
figure 25,000 was thrown out. I did
25,500 just because it's divisible by
three. Um, but the goal would be to
appropriate $8,500 each for foundation
dinners. Um, Lancaster Fairfield
Community Action, Lancaster Vineyard
Church Food Pantry. Once again, trying
to address the needs of their community.
um specifically spoke to Janette Curtis
and trying to assess what that need
looks like um as well as addressing you
know the geographical layout of the
city. So kind of picked one on the west
side, one in the center, one on the east
side. Um so there's you know that's what
the goal of this uh idea is trying to
accomplish. Uh simply just proposing it.
I have no pride of authorship with this.
I have, you know, I'm I'm more than
happy to take any feedback, you know,
take any input you guys have on this,
but like I said, this is something I've
seen other communities do and this is
something I think, you know, as elected
leaders here in the city of Lancaster,
we need to be a pillar of stability and
uh I think this would help contribute to
that in these trying times. So, that's
just my two cents and I'll leave it
there.
>> Okay.
Um, we talked a little bit briefly
before this, so I know everyone has a
copy. Whether you've had a chance to
look at it or read it, we can have some
[snorts] discussion. Um, if we want, if
we don't, next step would be ask law
director Hall to put it into a
resolution so we can present it and then
vote on it as we may. um obviously again
the floor is open for discussion on this
and if we want to talk about it in this
format or we don't want to talk about
it. Everybody was super chatty before
the meeting and then everyone clammed up
on me. So do we want to discuss or we
want to ask law director Hall to put it
in one of our a new resolution and go
from there.
>> Mr. Mayor, anybody? Would it go through
a committee first?
>> So, we brought it into finance because
of the financial piece.
>> Is that it?
>> Of it. So,
>> do it through finance.
>> Yeah. So, I'm fine with doing it through
finance. Just
>> I've got a couple thoughts on it first.
>> Well, I'm just stating for this
resolution there's no budget
appropriated. You'd have that's not in
the current one you showed you. It would
have to be
>> Yeah. So that's why we kick it to law
director hall to to make it
>> what what word did you use? I I used
fancy.
>> I said real.
>> You said real. I said fancy. Yeah.
>> No. And Todd Nettle's point. No, I get
that. I understand that 100%. I mean,
this is as fully baked as a non- lawyer
try and make this here. But like I said,
I just thought it was something, you
know, conversation worth having and and
legislation worth pursuing.
[clears throat] And I just want to
provide something tangible so we're not
talking in the abstract here. That's
all.
>> Uh, Mr. Mayor.
>> So, yeah, I have a couple thoughts.
Number one, the auditor just addressed
there's no current uh funding for
something uh of this nature. However, it
could be come from the un unencumbered
general fund balance is where it would
come from. Uh with that said, uh if
you're following this, you know, the
state, I'm sorry, the federal government
has been ordered to fund SNAP uh with
the $5 billion um money they had set
aside for contingency. That is not
enough to fund SNAP at 100%, but it is
enough to fund SNAP at right around 50%.
Um,
I think if we were to send it to the law
director for uh essentially making a
real resolution, we also would have be
be able to bring it back at the next
meeting. We might have new information
by then. Maybe things have changed by
then.
>> Certainly,
>> I understand what uh Councilman Bisjack
is proposing. I think other cities are
faced with the same and similar
situations. Some have already taken
action. Uh this being the first
opportunity for us to take any action.
Uh there has yet to be any impact on on
the community, but we know it's coming
if the federal government doesn't step
to the plate and fully fund SNAP. People
are going to be impacted. We know that.
Um, I'm hopeful,
I think, realistically hopeful that at
some point the government has to reopen
and that they're going to have to step
up and honor their commitments uh both
sides and uh hopefully sooner rather
than later. But if we put this together
uh coming through finance and have it
for the next meeting, we'll know a lot
more where we're at uh on the state and
national level. should know that uh if
you haven't heard, the state has funded
um
uh pantries for $24 million in
additional state funding.
>> 7 million is going to pantries, $18
million going to folks uh 50% of the uh
federal poverty line or lower.
>> That's the breakdown at least last I
read.
>> Good information. Thank you. Yeah,
>> but the state has stepped up. Some
cities and counties have stepped up and
it may be that city of Lanster should
step up. Uh but I think by putting in a
resolution coming through finance,
bringing it to the next meeting before
any significant impact hits the
community, we will know a lot more and
then we'll be able to take an
appropriate action going forward.
>> Okay.
>> Awesome. Thank you. So everyone's okay
with
law director Hall coming up with one,
then we'll introduce it at the next
meeting. Great. All right. Any other
discussion items for finance? Do we have
a do we have any idea how many meals
this would provide at each stage?
$8,500.
>> I I don't have that figure at this time.
I know I've been, you know, I'm really
grateful to Janette Curtis. She's been
uh she's been the resource I've been
working with on this one from 211. So I
I don't have that figure for you. I I
can try to endeavor to get that
information from her and and you know
see what that would yield, but yeah, I I
just don't at this time have that
information. This was this was an idea
that kind of sprang up on Friday. I
worked on a little bit over the weekend
and
>> just kind of seeing where things go from
there. So,
[snorts]
>> just curious how long how long $8,500
would go.
>> We will try to bring you additional
information so we know exactly what
impact it might make. That way we can
have it at the next meeting for you.
>> Right.
>> Anything else? We'll look for a motion
to adjourn finance.
>> So moved. [clears throat]
>> I'll second. and we're adjourned. It's
just us. 6:27,
>> right? Regular meeting of Lancaster City
Council will commence at 6:35.
The Frankie [music] Smith Funeral Home
and Crematory in Lancaster and the
Johnson Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore
have a long and wonderful history of
[music] serving our community. Feel free
to give us a call at 74-653652.
Stop in and [music] see us at either of
our two locations, 405 North Columbus
Street in Lancaster and 207 South Main
Street in Baltimore. Respect for
tradition, [music] regard for change.
>> Hi, I'm Corey Clark with Fairfield
County Job and Family Services. Our
mission [music] is to protect children
and elderly, encourage family stability,
and promote self-reliance for a stronger
community. We're honored to be selected
by the Buckeye family's Buckeye Cares
[music] program. That means Buckeye will
make a donation with each vehicle sold
this month. From all of us at Fairfield
County Job and Family Services, [music]
thanks Buckeye for your ongoing support
for local families.
>> [music]
>> Please rise if you're able and join me
in a moment of prayer.
God grant us the serenity to accept the
things that we cannot change, the
courage to change the things we can, and
finally the wisdom to know the
difference. I now call the November 3rd,
2025 Lancaster City Council meeting to
order. Please join me in the pledge of
allegiance. I pledge algiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the republic for which it stands. One
nation under God, indivisible, with
liberty and justice for all.
>> Please call the role.
>> Mr. Als here.
>> Mr. Vischack here.
>> Mrs. Who
>> here?
>> Mr. Lochenberg
>> here.
>> Mr. Skunberg
>> here. Miss Tiner here and Mr. Wing
>> here.
>> Let the record reflect that seven
members of Lancaster City Council are
present this evening. At this time, I'd
entertain a motion to excuse Council
Member Sie and uh Council Member Kits.
>> Mr. President, I like to make that
motion.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and second. All those
in favor, please signify by saying I.
>> I. All those opposed, same sign.
>> Reading and disposing of the journal.
Regular meeting minutes dated October
20th, 2025.
>> Mr. President, I like to make a motion
to receive and file the journal.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion, a second to receive
and file the journal. All those in
favor, please signify by saying I.
>> I.
>> All those opposed, same sign. We now
move to communications.
>> I have three this evening. I have a
series of emails October dated October
27th through October 28th, 2025
regarding ITGIS open gov renewal
contract RFL submitted by GIS manager
Scott Snder, Councilman Luckberg,
Council [snorts] Member Luenberg and
Stephanie Hall or Stephanie okay law
director Stephanie Hall. I can't do this
again this week. Um, email dated October
28, 2025 regarding ETMS FDA trial
opportunity submitted by fire chief
Slade Schultz. Email dated October 30th,
2025 regarding 911 tariff money
expenditures direct submitted by law
director Stephanie Hall.
>> So were those are reports of city
officials or communications?
>> Those are city officials.
>> Okay. So, um, I take a motion to, um,
have the reports of city officials.
>> Here, uh, Mr. President, I'd like to
make a motion to receive and file
reports of city officials.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion, a second to receive
and file the reports of city officials.
All those uh, in favor signify by saying
I.
>> I.
>> All those opposed, same sign. We'll now
move to communications.
>> Yes, I have two. I have email dated
October 24th, 2025 regarding community
block development on Washington Avenue
home. um submitted by Jack and Joyce
Brack Bill, Citizens of Lancaster. And
the second one is email dated November
3rd, 2025 regarding police public
records requests submitted by Grant
Pots, and he's a research specialist.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to receive and file the communications.
>> Second.
>> We have [snorts] a motion and a second
to receive and file the communications.
All those in favor, please signify by
saying I.
>> I.
>> All those opposed, same sign.
We have no special uh presentation or
awards this evening. We have no
petitions and memorials. We have now
reached the uh point in our agenda for
permission of voters and taxpayers to
address council. Do we have any
individuals here this evening that would
like to address city council?
Seeing none, we thank you for attending
to tonight's meeting. We now remove we
now move to the reports of standing
committees.
>> I have four of them this evening. I have
water water pollution committee meeting
minutes dated October 25th, 2025
submitted by Mr. Wing. Economic
development committee meeting agenda
dated October 29th, 2025 submitted by
Mrs. Hoop. Finance Committee meeting
minutes dated October 31st, 2025,
submitted by Mr. Skunover. Finance
committee meeting agenda dated October
31st, 2025, submitted by Mr. Skunover.
>> Mr. President like to make a motion to
receive and file reports of standing
committees.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and second to receive
and file the reports of standing
committees. All those in favor, please
signify by saying I.
>> I. All those post, same sign. Reports of
special committees.
>> There are no reports.
>> We have no public hearings this evening.
So we will now move on to the reading of
resolutions.
We're moving on with the third reading
of temporary resolution 8325.
A resolution to make appropriations from
planned 2026 budget expenses and other
expenditures of the city of Lancaster
for fiscal year 2026 and to establish
line item transfers authority for all
city departments. This is through
finance committee Mr. Skoover, Mr. Als.
>> Council member Skunover.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
that council place on the table
temporary resolution 8325.
>> Second. We have a motion and a second to
place on the table temporary resolution
8325.
Um, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack, yes.
>> Mrs. Kes,
>> I'm sorry. Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Lockenberg,
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Sully,
>> I'm sorry. Miss Tiner,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Wang?
>> Yes.
>> Temporary resolution 8325 is placed on
the table by a vote of seven to zero.
>> Mr. President, just just real quick
because I missed it. and finance. This
is just the budget we were tableabling.
The next version will be out sometime
this week. They had a issue with some of
the reports. So, okay.
>> I think everybody [clears throat] knew
to table it, but then I forgot to
mention or I forgot to recognize Miss
Woody uh during the finance meeting.
>> Oh, no problem. Thank you. Uh, [snorts]
temporary resolution 8425,
>> a resolution to increase and decrease
appropriations in the general fund 10001
for Lancaster Fire Department overtime
and to declare an emergency. This is
through safety committee, Mr. Bisjack
and Miss Tener.
>> Council member Bisjack.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I move that
council pass and gross and enter upon
the written record resolution
temporarily numbered 84-25.
>> Second.
>> Have a motion, a second to pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary resolution 8425. Any
discussion? Council member Bischack.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. Once again,
this is appropriating $75,000 from the
salary line item to the overtime line
item within the fire department. Uh this
is to accommodate for the fact that we
have not reached full staffing yet
within the fire department. And then
there's been an increase in uh injuries,
people um going off duty for medical
leave and and pulling light duty. So,
this uh transfer of funds will cover the
fire department for overtime for the
rest of this calendar year. That is all,
Mr. President.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Any further discussion?
Hearing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Lochenberg,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunover,
>> Miss Ter,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Wink,
>> Temporary resolution 8425 passes 10 to
0. Temporary resolution 8525.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance in the health
insurance management fund 7022 to amend
the certificate of appropriations with
the Fairfield County auditor and to
declare an emergency. Mrs.
Administrative Services Committee, Mr.
Luenberg and Mr. Visjek.
>> Council member Luckenberg.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I'd like to
make a motion that council pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
resolution temporarily numbered 85-25.
>> Second. We have a motion, a second to
pass from Gross and enter upon the
written record. Temporary resolution
8525.
Any discussion? Council member Luenberg.
>> Uh thank you, sir. Uh this we've
discussed this before. This is to cover
for a huge unexpected medical claim
coming uh from Children's Hospital over
a accident to a city employees child and
uh this will cover for that.
>> Thank you. Any further discussion?
>> Hearing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bizjack.
>> Yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop.
>> Mr. Lockenberg.
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Scooter.
>> Miss Teener.
>> Yes.
>> And Mr. Wink.
>> Temporary resolution 8525 passes 7 to
zero. We'll now move on to second
reading of resolutions. Beginning with
temporary resolution 8925. a resolution
to authorize the service safety director
to enter into a contract not to exceed
$500,000
with the A architectural [snorts] for
design and construction administration
of the Ed Road fire station project and
to declare an emergency. This is through
safety committee Miss Bisjack and Miss
Tener.
>> Council member Bisjack.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. This the
second of three readings. Second of
three readings on temporary resolution
8925.
We'll now move on to the first reading
of resolutions beginning with temporary
resolution 9025.
>> A resolution to authorize then announced
certificates for the community
development block grant fund 2073,
THIP home program fund 2083 and for the
healthy homes grant 2026
year end 2025 projected expenditures.
Mr. through economic development
committee Mrs. Hoop and Mr. Wing.
>> Council member Hoop.
>> This is first of three readings. First
of three readings on temporary
resolution 9025. Temporary resolution
9125.
>> A resolution to authorize the city of
Lancaster auditor to request in advance
of funds from the Fairfield County
auditor for the city's aortionment of
tax settlements for 2026. This is
through finance committee Mr. Skunover
and Mr. Als.
>> Council member Skunover.
>> Yes. Uh first of three readings, please.
>> First of three readings on temporary
resolution 9125.
Temporary resolution 9225,
>> a resolution to authorize the service
safety director to dispense with
competitive bidding due to a sole source
provider and to enter into a contract
for the city's enterprise asset and work
management software and to declare an
emergency is through administrative
services committee. Mr. Luckenberg and
Mr. Bisjack.
>> Council member Luckenberg.
>> First of three readings.
>> First of three readings on temporary
resolution 9225.
Temporary resolution 9325. A resolution
to appropriate from the unencumbered
balance and to amend the certificate of
appropriations with the county auditor
in the income tax fund 2016.
This through finance committee, Mr.
Skunover and Mr. Sully.
>> Council member Skunover. First of three
readings, please.
>> First of three readings on temporary
resolution 9325. Temporary resolution
9425. A resolution to increase receipts
appropriate from the unovered balance
and amend the certificate of other
sources and appropriations with the
county auditor in the hotel motel fund
was through finance committee Mr.
Skunover and Mr. ALS.
>> Council member Skunover. First of three
readings, please.
>> First of three readings on temporary
resolution 9425. Temporary resolution
9525.
>> A resolution to amend a portion or
portions appropriations. Sorry, budgets.
Then amend the certificate of other
sources and appropriations with the
county auditor and to declare an
emergency. It's through finance
committee. Mr. Skunover and Mr. Sully.
>> Council member Skunover. First of three
readings, please. First of three
readings on temporary resolution 9525.
That concludes our reading of
resolutions for this evening. And we
will [snorts] now move on to the reading
of ordinances beginning with the third
reading of temporary ordinance 5425.
[snorts]
an ordinance to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an FCC
notification for spectrum manager lease
and spectrum lease agreement with census
for the implementation of the smart
metering initiative by Lancaster
Municipal Gas. This is through service
committee um Mr. Als and Mr. Wing.
>> Council member Als. Uh, yes.
[clears throat] I move that we pass and
engross and enter upon the written
record ordinance temporarily numbered
54-25. [snorts]
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and second to pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance 5425.
Council member Als.
>> Yeah, there are two things that I get
excited about. I get excited about trees
and I get excited about gas meters.
>> This is a smart meter.
This meter has no mechanical parts. The
gas passes through it and is measured.
You can't fix it. In 20 years, the
battery is going to die [snorts] and
we're going to throw it away.
That's unheard of. I built meters for
almost 20 years and that's unheard of.
So, good for the gas department. It's
2025 and we are
they've been building automatic meter
reading devices since the 80s. So, we're
a little late to the game, but probably
it's a good thing because there was
nothing like that. Um,
it has in order for it to work, it it's
on a dedicated channel that's controlled
by the FCC and we have to apply for a
license. And that's what the legislation
is about. So I could spend a lot of time
talking about this if you'd like me to,
but
otherwise
[snorts]
>> any further discussion
>> hearing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bischek,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Locktoberg,
>> Mr. Skoonover,
>> yes.
>> Miss Teener,
>> yes. And Mr. Wink,
>> yes.
>> Temporary ordinance 5425 passes 7 to
zero. Temporary Ordinance 5525,
>> an ordinance to establish the
compensation for the council president,
council members, and the council clerk
for the term commencing payroll one of
2026. This through finance committee,
Mr. Skunover and Mr. Als,
>> council member Skunover.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 5525.
Second. We have a motion and second pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance 5525. Any
discussion council member Skun?
>> I don't have any.
>> Thank you. Any further discussion?
>> Hearing none, please call a role.
>> Mr. Eels,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Lockenberg,
>> Mr. Skoover,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Sully, I'm sorry. Miss Ter,
>> no.
>> And Mr. Wing?
>> Yes.
>> Uh, temporary ordinance 5525 passes 6 to
one.
Temporary Ordinance 5625,
>> an emergency ordinance declaring the
improvement to certain parcels
associated with the Sheridan Drive
project in the city to be public purpose
and exempt from taxation pursuant to
OC5709.40B
40B
requiring the owners of those parcels to
make service payments in lie of taxes.
Authorizing the city to require minimum
service payments and such payments are
agreed upon by developer establishing a
a municipal public improvement tax
increment equivalent fund for the
deposit of those service payments and as
applicable minimum service payments.
authorizing payments to the Lancaster
City Schools District specifying the
public infrastructure improvements that
directly benefit parcels in approving
related matters. Mr. Economic
Development Committee, Mrs. Hoop and Mr.
Scoover.
>> Council member Hoop.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I would like
to make a motion that council pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance 56-25.
Second
>> a motion and second to pass and gross
and enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance 5625.
Any discussion council member Hoop?
>> Um thank you. This is just a developer
tiff along Sheridan Drive and this is
just for the commercial part or the
multifamily. And just a reminder with
all of the tiffs um it will make the
schools whole um and it's
I think I already mentioned it's a
developer tip. So that's it.
>> Okay. Thank you. Any further discussion?
Hearing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bischack,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes. Mrs. Mr. Luenberg,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Skunhover,
>> Miss Tiner,
>> yes.
>> And Mr. Wayne,
>> Temporary ordinance 5625 passes 7 to
zero. We'll now move on to the second
reading of ordinances. and we will um do
a full reading um beginning with um
let's see
where do we which ones?
>> Okay, we'll just begin with temporary
ordinance 5725.
>> An ordinance to establish the
compensation for the city treasurer for
the term commencing payroll 1 2026 and
to declare an emergency. This is through
finance committee Mr. Skunover and Mr.
Als. Council member Skunover. It's a
second of three readings, please. Thank
you. Uh second of three readings on
temporary ordinance 5725. [snorts]
Temporary ordinance 5825.
>> An ordinance to adopt and enact the city
of Lancaster cyber security program
pursuant to a higher revised code
chapter 9 miscellaneous section 9.64
political subdivision cyber security. Um
this is through law committee. Mr.
Bisjack and Mrs. K.
>> Council member Bisjack. Thank you, Mr.
President. This will be the second of
three readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 58-25.
We'll now um um move to temporary
ordinance 5925.
>> An ordinance to amend the city of
Lancaster zoning map to change the
zoning of 35.506 506 plus or minus acres
identified as Fairfield County auditor
tax parcel number 053
41625000
from planned unit development district
to residential medium density district
and this through code enforcement in
zoning committee Mrs. Hoop and Mr. Fully
>> council member Hoop.
>> This is second of three readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 5925.
Temporary ordinance 6025.
>> And it's this an ordinance to amend the
Langster codified ordinances part 11
planning and zoning title 3 zoning and
property restrictions and to adopt
chapter 1131 short-term rentals. It's
through code enforcement and zoning
committee. Mr. Lochnerberg and Mr. Sully
C. Council member Luenberg,
>> a second of three readings, please.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 6025.
Uh temporary ordinance 6125,
an ordinance to establish the benefits,
titles, and compensation for management
and professional personnel
employed by the city of Lancaster, Ohio
for the year 2026 and to declare an
emergency. This is through finance
committee, Mr. Skunover and Mr. Als.
>> Mr. Skunover.
>> Second of three readings. Second of
three readings on temporary ordinance
6125.
Temporary ordinance 6225.
>> Yeah, we could do that.
>> Okay.
an ordinance to establish benefits,
titles, and compensation for those
employees who are not members of the
recognized bargaining units employed by
the city of Lancaster, Ohio for the year
2026 and to declare an emergency. This
through finance committee, Mr. Skunover,
and Mr. S.
>> Council member Skunover, we're going to
do second of three readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 6225.
We're going to take temporary ordinance
6325,
6425,
6525,
6625.
Um, together, if you would read them
all, please.
>> I sure will. Um, 6325, an ordinance to
establish the benefits, titles, and
compensation for seasoned interns to be
employed by the city of Lancaster during
the summer of 2026 and to declare an
emergency. This is through finance
committee, Mr. Screenber, Mr. Sullie.
Um, ordinance temporary 6425, an
ordinance to establish the benefits,
titles, and compensation for the
information technology administrator
office of the clerk of court
employed by the city of Lancaster, Ohio,
commencing the first pay period of 2026
and to declare an emergency finance.
This is through finance committee, Mr.
Skunover, Mr. Sullie. Uh temporary
ordinance 6525,
an ordinance to establish the benefits,
titles, and compensation for Fairfield
County Municipal Court Management and a
professional
personnel employed by the city of
Lancaster, Ohio for the year 2026 and to
declare an emergency. This through
finance committee, Mr. Scoover, Mr.
Sullie. And then finally, ordinance
temporary 6625, an ordinance to
establish benefits, titles, and
compensation for Fairfield County
Municipal Court judicial and probation
personnel employed by the city of
Lancaster, Ohio for the year 2026 and to
declare an emergency. This again is
through finance committee, Mr. Skunover
and Mr. Sully.
>> Council member Skunover be the second of
three readings on temporary ordinance 63
through 66. Thank you. Temporary
ordinance 6725,
>> an ordinance providing the issuance and
sale of the revenue notes in the
aggregate principal amount of 6,100,000
or 1,427
to pay cost of improving Ed Road,
Memorial Drive, and Michael's Way by
grading, widening, paving, curbing, and
improving bridges and railroad
crossings, relocating utilities, and
installing sidewalks, traffic signals
and signs and water sanitary and storm
water lines and facilities together with
all necessary impertinances there too in
declaring an emergency. This is through
finance committee Mr. Skunover and Mr.
Als.
>> Mr. Skoonover, it's a second of three
readings, please.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 6725, temporary ordinance
6825. An ordinance providing for the
issuance and sale of a revenue note in
the aggregate principal amount of
186,577
58 to reimburse Flagstar Bank NA for a
draw on the letter of credit in
connection with the cost of improving Ed
Road, Memorial Drive, and Michael's Way
by grading, widening, paving, curbing,
and improving bridges and railroad
crossing.
relocating utilities and installing
sidewalks, traffic signals and signs and
water, sanitary and storm water lines
and facilities together with all
necessary orertinances there too and
declaring an emergency through finance
committee Mr. Skunover and Mr. Als
Council member Skoover second of three
readings please.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 6825.
We'll now move on to the first reading
of ordinances beginning with temporary
ordinance 6925.
An ordinance to grant the South Central
Power Company, its access, its
successors, and assigns a franchise for
the right to acquire, construct,
maintain, and operate in the streets,
their theirs,
alleys, bridges, and public places in
the city of Lancaster, Ohio. lies for
the transmission and distribution of
electric power and energy to the city
and the inhabitants thereof for light,
heat, power, and other purposes and for
the transmission of the same within
through or across said city and to
declare an emergency. This is through
law committee, Mr. Bisjack and Mr.
Scooter.
>> Council member Bisjack. Thank you, Mr.
President. This is the first of three
readings.
>> First of three readings on temporary
ordinance 6925.
We have move we have concluded uh the
reading of our ordinances and
resolutions this evening. We do have
tabled legislation uh temporary
ordinance 3925.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. Um I'd like to
make a motion that we remove temporary
ordinance 39-25
uh from the table and then withdraw it
from further consideration.
>> Second.
We have a motion and a second to
withdraw temporary ordinance 3925 from
the table. Do we have to have that as
two separate or can we do one?
>> Sorry, you can do one.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> And to withdraw it. So, um, please call
the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Lochenberg,
>> Mr. Skunberg,
>> yes.
>> Miss Tinder, yes. And Mr. Wick,
>> yes. Uh temporary ordinance 3925 is
withdrawn by a vote of 7 to zero. Um we
will be leaving uh temporary ordinance
4925 on the table. Um we'll now move to
unfinished business. Is there any
unfinished business this evening?
Hearing none, we'll move on to new
business. We'll begin with committee
reports. Council member Bisjack. Uh
>> I have none at this time. Thank you, Mr.
President.
>> Thank you, Council Member Luckenberg.
>> Uh thank you. Yes. Um the administrative
services committee met on October 15th.
Some highlights from that meeting. IT
telecom uh department uh began the
installation of four new tornado signs
the following week. Uh they've been
working on an upgrade to the 911 system
which should be done by December 1. And
they've been putting working on putting
additional data into the open gov
system. Uh putting that into the cloud
HR department. Uh Danielle Williams
updated us all on the city employee
stats for year to date. That would be
new hires, departures, workers comp
claims, and uh we had a wonderful update
on the success of the Fairfield Medical
C Center's wellness and mental health
clinics for all city employees being
utilized significantly. Everyone's
pleased with how they're working.
um service safety director uh mentioned
that they're working on the 2026 city
budget diligently
and then we had an update from the city
facilities manager on the ongoing work
at city hall and he was initiating a
study on all the city buildings, tenant
spaces, parking lots, etc.
uh for 2026 to evaluate all aspects of
them from maintenance to uh efficiency
of use uh standpoint and then to
determine priorities for utilization in
the future and maintenance requirements
and scheduling in the coming years.
And if I get reelected tomorrow, our
next meeting would be tenatively
scheduled for the 3rd Wednesday of
January, uh, which would be January 21
in room 1897, city hall at 8:00.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, [snorts] Council Member Als.
>> Nothing new. Thank you, Council Member
Tiner.
>> Yes. Our next meeting is November the
14th at 7:30
committee.
>> Oh, I'm so sorry. public works and I
will not be scheduling next year. I
lost.
But actually, I do want to say something
though. As for the
um
uh our wages, I have not taken a raise
in all the 12 years I've been on
council. And I know during the election
it had been brought up that, you know,
we had taken raises and I have not for
12 years. So, I did want that out there.
>> Thank you, Council Member Skunover.
[clears throat]
>> Um,
not to I'm not going to I'm trying not
to sound like a broken record with the
budget budget and since I skipped over
you, I will defer my time if you'd like
to discuss it.
>> I don't know that I have a lot to add at
this point other than uh Mayor and I are
trying to finalize the budget this week.
We still have a couple changes that we
are trying to make and we are working
diligently on that and we are going to
try and have a final budget version out
to you hopefully by the end of this week
if not early next week. And I think that
that's all I have to say.
>> Um and aside from
like bring me an oxygen tank for all of
the third readings next meeting, that's
all I got. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Thank you. Uh, Council Member
Wing.
>> Uh, yes. Thank you, Mr. President. Uh,
next meeting for Water Water Pollution
Control Committee is, uh, two weeks from
today, 7:30 a.m. The 1897 conference
room. Uh, construction season is, uh,
nearing an end. So, our legislative
docket is not nearly as busy as it was,
but our employees in these departments
are still quite busy. Uh, water
department, we have two plants worth of
operators that are operating three
plants right now. So, they're doing a
great job there. and uh drove past Main
Street and Cherry Street today and glad
it's finally back open and the areas
that were affected by the sewer project
have been repaved.
>> Thank you, Council Member Hoop.
>> I have nothing.
>> Okay, thank you. We'll now move on to
announcement of scheduled meetings. Um,
I have negular oh next regular sessions
of council November 17th, 2025 at 6:30
p.m. here in council chambers. December
1st, 2025 at 6:30 p.m. here in council
chambers.
>> And December 15th,
>> did I have that on my last one? In
December 15th, um, 2025
at 6:30 p.m. in council chambers.
>> Thank you. which means we have reached
the point where we only have three
meetings left in 2025.
Um, regularly scheduled committee
meetings.
I have law committee nove November 7th
at 9:00 a.m. City Hall 1897 conference
room. Public works committee meeting
November 14th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall
1897 conference room. Water water
pollution committee meeting November
17th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room. Code enforcement
November 20th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall
1897 conference room. And then since we
only have three in December, I went
ahead and wrote those down as well. Um
safety committee meeting December 5th at
8 a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room.
service committee December 12th at 8 am
city hall 1897th conference room and
then the last one is water water
pollution committee meeting December
15th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference bill.
>> Reading of bills.
>> I have three of them today. Um I have
all of them from MNCO.
$102.70
for publication of ordinances.
$68.21
for notice for public of public notice
of short-term rentals. And then the
public notice for zoning map amendment
for $63.36.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. I'd like to
make a motion to pay the bills.
>> Second.
>> You have a motion and a second to pay
the bills. All those in favor, please
signify by saying I.
>> I.
>> All those opposed, same sign. We have no
need for an executive session. I would
now entertain a motion to adjurnn.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make that
motion to adjurnn.
>> Second.
>> Have a motion second to adjurnn. All
those in favor, please signify by saying
I.
>> I.
>> I. We are adjourned. Um, please remember
to sign your legislation this evening.
Thank you. I only have one. Anyone want
to see the
>> [music]
>> The [music] Frankie Smith Funeral Home
and Crematory in Lancaster and the
Johnson Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore
have a long and wonderful history
[music] of serving our community. Feel
free to give us a call at 74-653652.
Stop in [music] and see us at either of
our two locations, 405 North Columbus
Street in Lancaster [music] and 207
South Main Street in Baltimore. Respect
for tradition, regard for change.
Hi, I'm Corey Clark with Fairfield
County Job and Family Services. Our
mission [music] is to protect children
and elderly, encourage family stability,
and promote self-reliance for a stronger
community. We're honored to be selected
by the Buckeye family's Buckeye Cares
[music] program. That means Buckeye will
make a donation with each vehicle sold
this month. From all of us at Fairfield
County Job and Family Services, [music]
thanks Buckeye for your ongoing support
for local families.